you
[Music]
this morning in our pushing-the-limit
series we introduced you to a wounded
Army veteran who overcame incredible
odds to climb one of the world's most
treacherous mountains now Kilimanjaro is
Africa's highest peak at more than
19,000 feet but Adam Keyes recently made
it to the summit on prosthetic legs he
lost three limbs in Afghanistan and had
never climbed a mountain before he's
documented the trip for CBS this morning
Jan Crawford followed his journey Jan
good morning well good morning John I
mean this is an incredible story of
perseverance and faith and really just
making the most out of every minute that
you have I mean Adam Keyes says his
story shows you can do things that no
one would have ever thought possible if
you believe you can for anyone is a
soaring achievement but for Adam Keyes
the summit of Mount Kilimanjaro was only
part of the climb a few years ago taking
even one step was unimaginable on July
14th 2010 was the day I was injured he
was 26 years old an Army paratrooper on
patrol in Afghanistan when his truck
parked by a roadside bomb I said I open
the door the ID went off so that's the
last I remember he woke up two months
later for a while there it was
touch-and-go for a long long time
doctors initially gave Keyes less than a
1% chance of survival but to his mother
that meant he had a chance she came in
and the doctor said do you know how this
is I said yes that's my mother
she started crying and I you know I'm
getting teared up right now but she just
looked at the doctor and said I told you
so it was one of those things and what
did she know about you that they didn't
I guess mostly I am determined and when
I set my set my goals are something I
want to get it done but mostly I'm
stubborn and I like to prove people
wrong months went by before Keyes was
strong enough to learn the other
soldiers hadn't made it and that hit me
very hard I felt like I left my
because you know your team over there
and you uh some guys looked up to me and
not for much reason because I didn't
have the rank or anything but I was
always determined you're a leader I
tried to be I always wanted to be that's
for sure
enduring over 100 surgeries Keyes was
determined to survive for them i coded
six times I should have been dead by any
stretch of the imagination I should have
been dead but I was given a second
chance smile it was a journey of hope
and determination he learned to talk and
walk again and decided he would squeeze
the most out of that second chance
eventually he was competing on the hand
cycle in marathons before turning his
sights incredibly to the peaks of
kilimanjaro it's crazy
it is it's ambitious climbing mount I
mean most people with all four limbs in
the world could never do that well
that's a little bit of Drive again I
mean I use that as motivation to myself
as if it was easy everybody would do it
he saw that climb over 19,000 feet as a
message to others you're pushing
yourself to the limits to show people oh
yeah they can do it if you had that
obstacle in front of you you can't get
over it and I'm hoping to show that you
can do it but it does take a lot of work
you have to lean on other people it's
been Tyler a medic climbed alongside him
documented the trip for us feeling great
to the top a group of Tanzanian guides
became invested in his journey
at times carrying his mountain eyes
wheelchair and lifting his spirits
during the hardest moments they imagined
it would be brutal the outcome uncertain
but after five days of climbing on sore
limbs followed by freezing nights they
reached the top 2010 airborne all the
way and there at the summit Kees felt
even closer to his fellow soldiers his
goal now help others back home and
landing back in the US news of his
achievement spread quickly in the
airport and Kees got the recognition he
never seeks but deserves
now Adam isn't stopping there he got
back from the climb last week and then
he traveled to Chicago for the marathon
there this past weekend and now he's
getting ready to compete in the New York
City Marathon next month and at the same
time he's also raising money for wounded
warriors through his Facebook page this
is all part of an effort that he's
calling one step forward beyond oh wow I
mean what can't he do he said it was
theory but now we all want to meet him
Jan and a pool crying here on set
because he's just incredible to leave
that Purple Heart there to Wow you want
to meet him yes
what a hero Wow amazing